Speaker 1: All right, let's get into audience
questions for the week, very important political
issues and many other things to talk about.
Really important issue right off the top relates
to foreign policy.
I got a bunch of questions that were basically
some version of this.
Why do Trump supporters suddenly not want
us to leave Afghanistan, which Joe Biden is
doing, given that it was Donald Trump's idea?
Do you really don't know the answer to this
one?
I mean, listen, guys, that they liked it when
it was Trump's idea, but not when it's Joe
Biden doing it.
Look at the Iraq war.
George W. Bush in 2003 says it doesn't actually
say, but says even though it was not Iraq
that attacked us on 9/11, George W. Bush says
we're going to go into Iraq.
And whether it was trying to finish what his
father, George H.W. Bush, left undone or a
cynical political ploy because Saddam Hussein
was widely seen and accurately so is not a
particularly good guy, whatever the reason
was at that time, if you questioned what the
hell are we doing in Iraq?
You were called unpatriotic.
You were accused of not supporting the troops,
et cetera, incomes Trump and Trump says, hey,
you know what?
I was against going into Iraq.
That was a disaster.
I'm going to fix the Republican Party.
I'm not going to do stupid stuff like George
W. Bush.
And by and large, his followers in twenty,
fifteen, twenty sixteen fell for that, which
13 years before would have been unthinkable
in most Republican circles, except for some
like more extreme traditional libertarian
circles.
That's what Democrats have been saying all
along.
But when Trump says it, they believe it.
And it's the exact same thing with Afghanistan,
Trump said.
We're getting the hell out of Afghanistan.
And I'll talk about whether that makes sense
in a moment.
Hint it does.
And then when Joe Biden came in to office
and at the time, Republicans sort of said
they liked it.
I mean, I guess Joe Biden came in and said,
listen, I'm not saying we're not getting out
of Afghanistan, but Trump is such a buffoon.
My words, not his.
I'm pausing everything Trump was doing to
review it.
And then I'll make a decision.
And Joe Biden made the decision he's going
to keep going with the Afghanistan withdrawal.
And it will.
The announcement was instead of being in May,
which was Trump's idea, it will be by September
11th, a delay of about four months, even though
it appears to be happening more quickly and
will be done roughly similarly to when Donald
Trump says it's basically the same thing that
Joe Biden is doing is what Donald Trump is
doing.
But now all these Republicans and Trump are
saying, whoa, hold on a second, Joe Biden
has no plan for how to get out.
Did Trump he just said, we're leaving.
Joe Biden is getting out in a way that could
leave a vacuum.
That's always been the concern.
What's new about that?
So they're just pathetic political statements.
I wouldn't pay too much attention to them.
For the most part, foreign policy in this
way, I don't believe is really even going
to play a role in twenty twenty four unless
something dramatically changes.
So it's very transparent cynicism and the
analysis is super simple.
They liked it when Trump was doing it, when
Biden's doing it.
By definition, it's not good because Biden,
as they see it, is incompetent and won't do
it the right way now in terms of getting out.
It's just time, and I've said for a long time,
when you break something, you own it, then
you've got to fix it.
And so when this applied to Afghanistan in
this applied to Iraq, when you go in, as the
United States did, and wreak havoc and cause
chaos without even evaluating whether your
motivations were good or bad, like I'm not
even including that in this conversation.
As relevant as it is, if you caused the chaos,
you have some responsibility to fix it.
And the question then becomes how many years,
how many administrations worth?
And at a certain point, particularly when
you realize just staying won't fix it.
You have to say this is as far as the responsibility
goes and it's time to get out.
So are we responsible for the state of affairs
currently in Afghanistan as well as in Iraq?
Of course.
Would our responsibility dictate that we stay
even if we only continue to make it worse
or at least not better?
I think there is a limit to it, and I think
that limit has been reached 20 years.
So it is time to get out.
Things may go downhill as a result, and that
is going to have to be dealt with.
But at a certain point, the responsibility
has to stop.
So the Trump supporters now saying Biden shouldn't
get out, but Trump was and I like that then,
but I don't like it now.
Don't pay attention to them.
But there are real serious questions about
the limits of American responsibility when
we get into these quagmires abroad.
And that's a much bigger topic for a different
day.